-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan
failed to secure
enough votes today
in the second round of voting
to become House Speaker,
and received only 199 votes.
That's worse
than he did yesterday.
If they keep doing votes,
he's eventually
gonna get to zero.
And then he'll fade away like
Marty McFly in a family photo.
[ Laughter ]
The White House announced
last night
that President Biden's
scheduled stop in Jordan
has been canceled,
making it the second Jordan
to get shut down this week.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden arrived
this morning in Israel,
making him the first president
to visit Israel
during a time of war,
which is pretty dangerous.
But he should be okay once
he makes it down the stairs.
[ Laughter ]
The Treasury Department
announced new sanctions today
against 10 entities
that are linked to Hamas,
including the cryptocurrency
firm Buy Cash.
Oh, uh, was a cryptocurrency
firm up to no good?
[ Laughter ]
And it's called Buy Cash?
"Hey, what's a good
non-suspicious name
for a crypto firm?
How about Buy Cash?"
[ Laughter ]
If I drove past a strip mall
and there was a store
called Buy Cash,
I would lock my doors
and call the police.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Congresswoman
Anna Paulina Luna
reportedly brought
her newborn baby
to yesterday's
House Speaker vote.
Well, congratulations
to the new mom
and the new Speaker!
[ Laughter ]
Baby with a gavel!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Baby with a gavel.
That's one of comedy's
first rules.
Can't go wrong with a baby
with a gavel.
Former President Trump yesterday
attacked the judge
overseeing
his civil fraud trial,
in a post on Truth Social,
and said he's serving "as judge,
jury, and everything else."
I'm guessing this was after
three failed attempts
to spell executioner.
[ Laughter ]
[As Trump] Judge, jury,
and big guy with ax and mask.
[ Laughter ]
-[Normal voice] That's right.
Trump attacked the judge
overseeing his civil fraud trial
despite being under
a partial gag order.
Yeah, I don't think you can...
Yeah, don't...
[ Gibberish ]
[Bleep]
I know, I stumbled
on the wording earlier,
and I didn't rewrite it,
and it's my fault.
Okay, here we go.
Alright. Yeah.
Let's go back and take it again.
It's definitely...
This isn't gonna
throw it at all.
[ Laughter ]
I don't -- I don't even think
they've noticed I flubbed up.
[ Laughter ]
I've played it so smoothly.
That's right.
Trump attacked the judge
overseeing his civil fraud trial
despite being under
a partial gag order.
Yeah, you don't think
you can shut Trump up
with a partial gag order,
do you?
You can't even shut him up
with a full gag order.
You could put them in the full
Hannibal Lecter outfit,
and he would still find a way
to get the word out.
[ Laughter ]
In an effort to reduce pollution
caused by microplastics,
a European Union ban on the sale
of loose plastic glitter
went into effect this week.
Some great news that, sadly,
there was no way to celebrate.
[ Laughter ]
United Airlines
has reportedly decided
to implement
a new boarding strategy
that allows economy passengers
in window seats to board first.
Meanwhile, Spirit Airlines
has decided
to streamline boarding
with a starting gun.
[ Laughter ]
The US Mint yesterday announced
that journalist Ida B. Wells
will be honored
with her face on a quarter.
Because what greater honor
than being bounced
into a Solo cup
by a drunk freshman?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Netflix recently
unveiled plans
for its first
live sports event,
which will feature
Formula One drivers and golfers
teaming up to compete
in a golf tournament.
So, if you love the intense,
high-speed excitement
of Formula One racing,
get ready to strap yourself in
for some golf.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
We are off and running.